what this does is this kicks off the uh
really like the the Phoenix Saga story
you know for the most part with regards
to Jason Aaron it's called enter the
Phoenix right now um on the surface when
I initially saw this I was like man I
don't know man another Phoenix Saga
story but I kind of like the way this is
done right the motivation behind it's
pretty flimsy but I like the way that
it's done right this is really really
really really cool right so in this
video we pick up with Dr Doom versus
Captain America which I think is a great
battle right it's a great little
conflict here so um the way this picks
up is we knew the Phoenix force was
basically coming back and that's one of
the things understand about Jason
Aaron's comic book work if you look at
this in isolation it seems silly but if
you look at it in the the nature of
which Jason Aaron writes which is
usually building up to a bigger story
then it's just a simple stepping stone
is really all it is the whole thing here
is Captain America is basically kind of
in this place it almost looks like a
forest or like idrasil or something like
that and kind of talking about the
nature of him as a hero right the nature
of him as a character and one of the
things that he lays out here is that for
him he has this kind of life that he
lives where he doesn't really see
himself as being spectacular and that
was one of the the things that kind of
kept Steve Rogers grounded and kind of
kept him pretty normal it was really
understanding his place in the bigger
picture because the reality is Steve
Rogers just a guy who can run really
fast and punch really hard and he's good
at Battle strategy and that's
essentially it right there really is
nothing special about Captain America
and there there are a mountain a
veritable mountain of characters who
could overpower and destroy him with
ease what makes Captain America so
significant in Marvel Comics is the fact
that he is a battle hardened guy that he
is so good with military strategy The
Experience he brings to the table during
his time in World War II despite having
been frozen for a number of years but
he's the guy who could basically
organize the the superhero Community
he's the guy that everybody looks to
when they're trying to figure out what
they need to do when they're facing off
a particular conflict right so uh
Captain America's position in the
Superhuman Community is really more of a
position of respect and ceremony than
than just outright raw power but it's
one of these things where as soon you
know in the middle of this whole thing
where he's kind of musing and talking to
himself suddenly he's attacked by Dr
Doom right now the way that Jason Aaron
writes Dr Doom is amazing because I love
love Dr Doom as a character right I have
always loved Dr Doom as a character he's
not my absolute favorite but I've always
loved him as a villain of sorts because
he's so arrogant and so full of huis
that he refers to himself in the third
person right which is just just
downright
arrogance to not even refer to yourself
as me and just refer to yourself in the
third person right like what's going on
guys this is Rob and Rob is going to be
talking about Avengers right now here's
what Rob thinks when it comes to the
Avengers story like it's just it sounds
arrogant right it sounds funny but it
sounds arrogant at the same time and I
love that but at the same time Doom's
also one of those guys where when things
pop off you want him on your side man
like you want you want Doom to Ally with
you because he just brings so much to
the table but it's it's one of these
things where he kind of talks about this
nature of the Phoenix force and saying
that what he has right now is a portion
of the Phoenix Force's power and he's
kind of like you know uh this little
fragment this little portion that you
gave me Doom does not do a pair of
teeths you will give me a full totality
of your power right we will end this
farce of a tournament it reminds me of
the scene from borax when uh when he's
talking to the chick and he's just like
I will look through your Treasures now
that kind of a thing nonetheless you
know it's basically Dr de has received a
portion of the Phoenix's power and is
going toe-to-toe with Captain America
right and the idea is to take you know
or to eliminate Captain America in in
the tournament now we don't really know
the basis behind this tournament we
don't really know why it's happening
we'll find out here in a second uh we
just simply know that seemingly for Dr
Doom killing off uh Steve Rogers is the
only way for him to attain the full
totality of the Phoenix's Powers problem
with this is Captain America hits him
with the shield and when the Shield
comes back the Phoenix Force has been
imbued to Captain America right so we
just took it off of Dr Doom like that
now again there's some stuff going on
here that we haven't really seen before
we haven't really seen the Phoenix Force
change possession like that right to
change from you know use an inanimate
object as a vector between itself and a
host usually the Phoenix just bonds
itself to a person and that's basically
it right I mean even when you had
Avengers versus X-men and you had the
Phoenix 5 it worked the same way right
branded Iron Man basically screwed up
the Phoenix force and split it into five
separate pieces but it's still bonded to
individual ual and so it's it's really
really cool and interesting the way this
is done because Steve Rogers as a host
for the Phoenix looks amazing and that's
what's so cool is because this is just
kind of another notch in the belt of
Captain America Captain America has had
the Cosmic Cube he's used it on more
than one occasion he had The Infinity
Gauntlet we saw that during the events
of Jonathan Hickman Avengers and New
Avengers like the greatest comic book
story ever told is one of these things
where Captain America's done all kinds
of stuff he's lifted the hammer of Thor
he's controll the casket of ancient
winners we've seen him do all kinds of
things right and so this is just kind of
another notch in the belt of Steve
Rogers now what we end up doing is
jumping back to an earlier point in time
and then this is when we really get our
explanation in terms of what's going on
here and the idea is that basically just
outside of Avengers Mansion a volcano is
essentially immersed and the Phoenix
force is inhabiting this volcano and so
when the question of the Avengers is how
in the world did this thing this this
thing get here right like what in the
world is going on that you basically end
up having uh neyar the Submariner who
just kind of pops out of nowhere and
it's just like I'm the one who did this
right like I am the one who summoned the
Phoenix to Earth and it really seems to
be in a lot of ways a simple Vendetta
which is getting rid of the surface
world for neyar it's a lot deeper than
that because the surface world has in a
lot of ways been the cause of and and
the source of a lot of problems in the
Atlantean world right pollution
different things like that and so was a
desire to just get rid of the surface
dwellers and so he effectively summoned
the Phoenix to Earth and then it's going
to bond with it in order to attain the
Phoenix's power and just wipe out the
Wipe Out All Humans across the surface
the problem is that as soon as he gets
there he's immediately met by Wolverine
now an important thing to understand is
Wolverine was sent here by the X-Men and
the reason why is because we know just
from Marvel publication history the
X-Men have an exceedingly close tie with
the Phoenix now for those of you guys
who were new to comics and you don't
really know what that means the
important thing to to really just grasp
out of this is that Jean Gray was the
first real earth-based human to become a
host for the Phoenix more recently
Marvel's changed that and they
established that there were actually
other people before Jean Gray who were a
host for the Phoenix Force but even with
that being the case Jean Gray was the
first person to ever use the full
totality of the Phoenix's power and then
actually become a villain while she had
the Phoenix's power that was the whole
idea behind the dark Phoenix story
launch she essentially went crazy and uh
ultimately ended up becoming a bad guy
and so the X-Men's history with the
Phoenix force is very very strong
because then you have Rachel Summers
who's the the daughter of Jean Gray and
cyclops from an alternate reality who
was a host for the Phoenix Emma Frost
who was the leader of the X-Men at one
point had possession of the Phoenix
force and so it's one of these things
where the Phoenix is just almost
intertwined with the mutant population
uh inexorably right there's just no real
way to to eliminate that kind of
relationship there and so wherever
whenever the Phoenix shows up on Earth
the X-Men are not far behind right so
that's one of the things if you ever see
the Phoenix in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe if the mutant population has
not been established by then it will
very very soon right I think that you'll
see mutants established before before
the Phoenix Force but that's just really
kind of how those things work right and
so it's it's kind of crazy because you
sort of jump back to the the moment with
Captain America and Dr Doom fighting
each other and Captain America in
possession of the Phoenix's power and
then in turn Doom having his possession
of the the Phoenix's power really just
kind of go toe-to-toe and start battling
each other now as you would expect
because Dr Doom is so capable and
because the Phoenix Force abilities
basically just augment his own powers
that he goes to kill Captain America the
problem is it doesn't work right like he
it just it does not successfully work
every time he tries to kill Captain
America Captain America's willpower
keeps him alive and it's really just
done by way of the fact that Captain
America's his willpower is kind of the
main focus of his character right his
desire to always win so like he always
gets back up he refuses to just kind of
acques and quit and so because that it
doesn't necessarily seem to be a battle
to the death so much as a a a battle
that will determine whose willpower is
stronger right and so it's a it's a
really cool moment when that happens
because you literally have Steve Rogers
where he's just kind of being pummeled
over and over and over again and sends
out this psychic projection of his
younger self right when he was very
small very scrawny and in the end that's
really where his willpower comes from
right the fact that even when he was a
guy that couldn't do anything to anybody
and was in probably his weakest form he
would still keep fighting right it's his
conviction his courage his strength of
character that's what makes Steve Rogers
who he is Dr Doom lacks that right Dr
Doom has conviction but Dr Doom's
willingness to go the limits is only
contingent based on whether or not he
gains a personal benefit to something he
doesn't fight for anybody but himself
right that's really kind of how Dr Doom
works and so once he realizes that Steve
Rogers will always be resurrected and
the Phoenix force will never let him die
then he's just kind of like okay fine
then I ACS right I quit like Doom
forfeits this thing and ultimately Doom
is whisked away now kind of jumping back
to the current moment and getting a bit
of a of a fullon and and really more
tangible explanation here that you end
up having you know again this kind of
Revelation given by Neymar Wolverine and
Neymar sort of fight for a little while
the rest of the Avengers show up and
face off against the forces of Neymar
from Atlantis and then suddenly the
Phoenix emerges right the Phoenix
finally just sort of appears and then
descends down and then ultimately ends
up just kind of Basking everybody in the
area in the glow of its power and then
just starts snatching people away right
so tala Neyo the Submariner uh Thor
right Carol daners Captain America just
all these various people who were here
and seemingly other people in different
parts of the world and so again that's
where things are kind of Bonkers it's a
cool moment and it's awesome to really
see that to see that take place and so
following the defeat feed or really the
the acquiescence of Dr Doom kind of
forfeiting in this and then giving up
seemingly Captain America is transported
back to the white hot room now we don't
actually know if that's where he's at
but it looks like that's where he's at
for those you guys who are new to Comics
the white hot room is it's one of these
things where it's kind of depicted and
explained in different ways in Marvel
Comics the most common explanation that
comic book fans go with is that it is at
the center of the incron crystal which
is basically this Crystal that's kind of
like a gateway to the Multiverse right
so if you were to enter the mcon crystal
it would be like walking through a
hallway of doors and you could access
any Multiverse by going through the
crystal uh if you were to like destroy
one of the doors quote unquote or
destroy the access point to that that
Universe it would actually start sucking
that Universe in and it would basically
lead to that universe's destruction
right so destroying a door in the
hallway of doors that makes up the mcon
crystal would lead to the destruction of
a universe destroy enough of those or
fracture the mcon Crystal and you'll
destroy the Multiverse right the the
mcon crystal will quite literally turn
into a multiversal black hole and start
sucking everything in and then
ultimately it'll create a new Big Bang
and everything will be born again but
regardless of of how you slice it the
white hot room is basically just where
those individuals who are either
possessed by the Phoenix and are using
the full totality of its power or being
held by the Phoenix end up residing
right so again we're just kind of
assuming that's the case we're not given
a definitive explanation but because of
the fact that Captain America is the one
who arrives back here seemingly Captain
America won right you've got Jennifer
Walter She-Hulk you've got wolver rain
and you've got tala who are here of
course you also have Neymar the
Submariner and then you have several
other people and that's what's so cool
is it basically shows us there's a ton
of people who were here right you've got
Luke Cage you got Howard the Duck which
is awesome you've got Hyperion which by
the way when Hyperion gets the Phoenix
force it looks amazing like it it it's
it's it's stupidly cool but you've got
uh you've got Moon girl and devil
dinosaur which I love Moon girl and
devil dinosaur and then you got man
thing right so like you got Black Knight
you got a whole host of characters here
shangqi that kind of a thing right you
got a bunch of folks going on here and
so ultimately these guys are the ones
participating in this tournament and
seemingly it will just kind of continue
to bounce around until ultimately a
Victor is formed so initially this kind
of opens up with black panther now
here's a cool thing to understand about
this right I love Chadwick Bosman as
Black Panther in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe unfortunately he passed before
we really got to see the full fruition
of his character Black Panther in the
comics is nuts he's amazing I I think
okay so here's the thing a lot of people
ask me this what's the best black
panther story ever the best black
panther story ever of all time really
comes down to three writers right
Christopher priest Reginal hland and uh
Jonathan Hickman oh my God if you guys
never saw if you guys remember read
Jonathan Hickman Avengers and New
Avengers check out the playlist down in
the description right it's just it's a
ridiculously good it's so amazing it's
such a ridiculously good story anyway so
this basically opens up with black
panther kind of amusing to himself now
while I will say that Jason Aaron of
course doesn't handle black panther as
well as Jonathan Hickman did he still
does it exceedingly well right so one of
the things that makes talo such a
formidable guy is one like the abilities
he has from the panther God but two his
intelligence and his ability to be
dispassionate in a situation right and
so he kind of talks about this this
whole concept that's going on and he
kind of says that like Steve Rogers you
know punches the scenery impatiently
because all he really knows how to do is
fight Thor laughs to hide his brooding
Carol Danvers Broods to hide her
laughter Tony armors his fragile ego one
egotistical word at a time like we all
have our routines and that's the cool
thing here right it's one of the things
about Black Panther when he originally
joined the Avengers of Marvel Comics he
did it to spy on the team to make sure
they were never going to be a credible
threat to wakanda is one of the coolest
Revelations that came out of came out of
Marvel at the time uh back in the the
'70s really well it wasn't really until
the70s that you kind of find out what
was going on but it was cool right the'
70s ' 80s that kind of a thing and so uh
he kind of says like you know in the
moment before a battle I seek to empty
myself of all but the essential one must
fight with great emotion but one must
not fight emotionally and that kind of
stuff right there like that philosophy
is really what makes black panther so
incredibly cool right so as he's kind of
here and sort of meditating suddenly
he's set upon by the arrival of the man
thing now the man thing is a character
you almost never hear about I wouldn't
be surprised if you saw some reference
to the man thing in Doctor Strange
Multiverse of Madness right the reason
why is because the man thing guards the
Nexus of all realities in the Florida
Everglades and you can't simply just go
through the Nexus you have to basically
pass the man thing who's a test and the
idea is that those individuals who know
fear burn at the touch of the man thing
and that's why you see this kind of
Engagement here where even even uh Black
Panther says that right like those who
know fear burn at the touch of the man
thing so literally he touches Black
Panther in that moment when he just lays
a finger on him if black panther was
scared he would have died just like that
like would have just burst the flames
and died such as it is Black Panther is
not afraid of and so it's the coolest
thing in the world to see him survive
this whole thing right see him survive
this at that point it just turns into a
knockdown drag out fight now the
disappointing thing about this is that
while black panther is a great character
and him being imbued with the power of
the Phoenix is super impressive in the
end it's momentary I mean I will say
black panther with the Phoenix Force
looks amazing like it looks amazing I
love the way this looks and I kind of
want to see him say like this forever
because it just it looks like it looks
it looks like the coolest thing ever
right like it's awesome right basically
what I'm saying right he he just it
looks it just looks awesome but the
reality is Jason eron kind of makes this
so fast because it's designed to show
what tal is capable of when he attains
such a high level of power and we've
seen him do that before right when tala
had when he got The Infinity Gauntlet
when Black Panther had The Infinity
Gauntlet during Jonathan Hickman Secret
Wars dude it was nuts right he literally
LED an army of the Dead against uh
against God King Doom against Emperor
doom and had had had like no fear his
conviction his resolve was absolute and
it was one of the coolest things right
so essentially he just kind of punches a
hole to the man thing pummels him and
then Burns him right now the reality is
the man thing will regrow in a lot of
ways he's kind of Marvel's version of
Swamp Thing so he'll always regrow he'll
always end up coming back and then black
panther basically shows back up to the
white hot room now there is a little bit
of discussion here among the various
people who were in this spot who kind of
talk about what's going on and where
where they're at and what's happening
wolver rain answers it pretty quickly
and basically saying that they're in the
white hot room they're basically in a
place that's reserved for for those
individuals who have the power to
possess the Phoenix Force but it also
makes sense that because the Phoenix is
using them for a tournament the Phoenix
would use it as a way station right just
kind of use it as a place to hold them
and they're effectively cut off from
everything right so like black panther
for example cannot commune with the
panther guy or with the the Black
Panthers of the past he can't even talk
to his own Panther God right he's kind
of shut off from all these different
places but suddenly there's people here
that we weren't really aware of before
right like you've got shaa who's the the
queen of the Savage land you've got the
orb I don't even know why he's here but
ultimately you have name of the
Submariner who kind of of gos and sort
of boasts and kind of says look like you
know I don't know like what's you know I
I know what's going on but like at the
end of the day like I don't really care
about any of these people's bickering
like just tell me who I need to fight
and that'll be it now he's kind of
trying to go people into a conflict so
we can kind of weed individuals out
one-on-one now ultimately She-Hulk is
the one who takes the bait but she's
immediately attacked and kind of set
back by the Phoenix and it's like no
right like you will fight who I want you
to fight and so the next person selected
in this tournament is Luke Cage now Luke
Cage with the the Phoenix Force yeah it
kind of looks okay right it's not the
the greatest thing in the history of the
world he fights American Eagle who's
basically just a guy from the Navajo
Nation so it's almost kind of like John
proudstar to a degree it's pretty
interesting you've got shaa you know the
the she devil basically the leader of
the Savage land for those you guys who
don't know what that is the Savage land
is a place in Antarctica where you
basically have like dinosaurs and stuff
like that and different people have used
it as a base of operations but it's like
prehist like the the Earth and
prehistoric times which is confined to
that area of the Antarctica now the
reason why it exists is because of the
beyonders who are kind of conducting a
small scale experiment and essentially
doing an almost Noah's Arc kind of
situation which is where they had a race
travel around the world and then
basically round up all these different
flora and fauna and then drop them off
in the Antarctic and leave them there uh
and then it kind of allows you know
people to use it for their own ends and
there's all kinds of like civilizations
and societies there but at the end of
the day they're fighting on the blue
area of the Moon which is a portion of
the Moon that has oxygen of course she's
not going to fight uh she's not going to
fight Luna lunella lafette right the
moon girl she's going to fight like
Devil dinosaur devil dinosaur of the
Phoenix Force looks terrifying it looks
horrifying oh would never want to fight
a t-rex with a phoenix
force it looks horrifying but you kind
of see these things right you know in in
subterrania basically uh the realm of a
combination of the deviants and the
moleman You' basically got Jane Foster
facing off against the orbs so not a
whole lot going on here one of the cool
moments that takes place is at wgore
Mountain right which is technically the
home of the high evolutionary and you've
got Hyperion who's imbued with the power
of the pho now the reality here is of
all the people in this group the most
powerful just under ordinary
circumstances is hyperion the closest
that Marvel has to Superman and Marvel
Comics he's like the definitive Superman
analog in Marvel Comics but uh but yeah
him with the Phoenix Force looks cool
and so having his power bolstered by
that of the Phoenix he dwarfs everybody
here in all honesty it's the one part of
the story that I don't like in terms of
the way that Jason Aaron handled it and
the sense that Hyperion with all this
power is just kind of like man like you
know I can feel my fingers like reaching
into Infinity right like I've got Cosmic
awareness now right he basically knows
everything going on across the universe
and then becomes afraid of it because in
his mind it's like oh my God like I'm
going to go crazy I'm going to use this
power for evil different things like
that and kind of has this existential
crisis and then just gives up right and
then you get to see Shang CHI with the
Phoenix Force which looks really cool
but he just gives up and it's probably
the weakest moment it's like really
Jason Aaron you gave you gave the
Phoenix Force to essentially Superman
and you have him give up like come on
but at the same time I also kind of
understand because this guy could have
just overpowered and destroyed everybody
right like everybody would have just
been completely and totally obliterated
and so there's really not a whole lot
you can do there now the next thing that
we get is is actually in grenwich
village where Doctor Strange exists at
least in Doctor Strange's Kitchen where
you have Howard the Duck facing off
against the Red Widow now the Red Widow
is a new creation by by Jason Aaron
right she appeared in uh in Avengers
Issue Number 10 we know that she is not
yena Bova uh just because of the fact
that yena Bova appeared way back in the
day she's been around for a long long
time in Marvel Comics so you know she's
not really new here I mean she appeared
back in an inhuman story in 2005 so you
know Yola is not a new character as far
as red widow goes she never talks or or
well it's obviously a chick right she's
got boobs but like she never talks uh
only women are ever trained to become
widows anyway but like she never talks
we never hear anything from her we have
no indication of who this chick is right
so it's a wholly different Beast of
course she beats Howard the Duck to
death right destroys Howard the Duck and
that's kind of it but following that you
have kind of the the Phoenix Force
letting off this psychic projection and
then meeting with black panther now it
is to a degree the Phoenix but it almost
seems like it's kind of not in the sense
that this being acts autonomously and
refers to the Phoenix as like she and
her as an other entity Beyond herself so
it's a it's a little interesting to see
it kind of related to in that way but
it's really cool because at the end of
the day this this haringer more or less
says like like tells black panther the
Phoenix wants you right like you're the
person the Phoenix wants and ultimately
black panther has like the coolest
moment here right only tala would look
at the Emissary of a multiversal force
of energy that represents the sum total
of all life that has ever currently does
and will ever exist that could burn
universes to Ash and respond to a
statement from this Emissary and saying
I will make you an offer that if you
allow me me like if you become a host of
The Phoenix then we can burn the name of
wakanda in the skies but if you turn it
down then like then we'll destroy
wakanda only to Cha would respond to
that and saying actually I'll make you
an offer right either you can leave here
or I can destroy you right I will spare
your life if you go away and then like
only tala would do that only tala would
look at like a multiversal force of
energy and be like I will spare your
life if you leave like just it's the
most baller thing ever right like that
is a Man Without
Fear that is a Fearless dude but like
literally black panther that's that's
the thing man like black panther is cool
like people love black panther because
of Chad bossman's Port portrayal in the
MCU but like you don't know the half of
how awesome black panther is in Marvel
Comics right he's just he is so cool
right like but one of the coolest things
about him is as loyalty as king to
wakanda make no mistake no matter what
you see black panther do as like a as
like an Avenger or if he's fighting
alongside the X-Men or when he took the
role of Daredevil and became like black
panther The Man Without Fear it doesn't
matter if black panther has to make the
choice between saving what wakanda and
letting the world die he'll let the
world die right he'll let the world burn
before he lets anything happen to
wakanda right he'll even turn against
the world and destroy it if he has to in
order to save his people his his his
loyalty to his citizens is that strong
it's just he's he's God he's such an
amazing character I love the character
of Black Panther and so whether it's
because of the fact that he was mounting
off to the Phoenix or because of the
fact that the next round is started
regardless of what the reason was Black
Panther is basically teleported back to
the Florida Everglades where he faces
off against Nighthawk now here's the
thing about Nighthawk and not sure I'm
really on board with this Nighthawk is
Kyle Richmond who's an interesting
character I'll be honest with you guys I
think the biggest moment Nighthawk ever
had is when he was basically shanghaied
in uh into the Squadron Sinister by Roy
Thomas and and salba Sima back in 1969
right like that whole Squadron Sinister
thing he's been around ever since but
he's just besides that he's never been a
character that I cared about I'm sure
there are some super hardcore Nighthawk
fans who love his character will be like
no Rob that's wrong he had all these
amaz amazing moments and if he did feel
free to list him down in the comments
right I'm not goingon to hold it against
you I mean some of them might be really
cool but he was never really an
interesting character to me what I'm a
little on the fence about is that the
last time we saw him was in Squadron
Supreme volume 4 and basically it turned
out that like he'd been impersonated by
a scroll um I don't really know what
they're doing with that but at the
moment Jason Aaron almost kind of seems
to be trying to create an almost Black
Panther and Ney or the submarin or
Grudge between Black Panther and
Nighthawk I know black pan I know
Nighthawk was like part of the Defenders
and there's some history there things
like that but the reality is the the
various grudges and and the issues that
black panther and and uh Nighthawk had
never came anywhere close to being as
cool as The Grudge between like Black
Panther and Neymar right but at the end
of the day essentially Kyle Richmond has
kind of been working to like infiltrate
and influence wakanda and there's kind
of a lot going on there with regards to
what's what's been happening in the
Black Panther stories uh by tanasi coats
and yeah His Name Escapes me the guy who
took over after but uh at the moment the
fight just kind of comes down to them
right now again it's just another stage
in this conflict of who's going to be
the last person standing that gets to
wield the Phoenix force and so again the
last little battle that we get to switch
to is one between Mya Lopez and Neymar
the submariners but Maya Lopez is
basically a character who goes by the
name of Ekko right she appeared back in
Daredevil in 1999 with uh with David
Mack I think was the one that wrote him
and then reappeared again in Ryan
Michael bis's uh New Avengers which was
great but Maya Lopez basically has the
ability to mirror the power or mirror
the fighting style of anybody she sees
by just watching it right like for
example during the old um 1999 Daredevil
story she actually saw a fight between
Daredevil and Bullseye and then was able
to like copy the moves of both and then
went to go white Daredevil and actually
overpowered him right so like it was
really cool to see that happen she's
like a female version of of Taskmaster
more or less except Tony Masters can do
what he do partly because of he was him
being born with that power and then also
because his power was bolstered right by
like a formula that he that he took so
uh there were there's some things that
kind of enhance him and make him you
know a little more capable uh just
beyond what he was normally able to do
but Maya Lopez is cool right and so Maya
Lopez kind of being imbued with this
power of the Phoenix going by the name
Ekko while all standard the measurement
it looks like she'll probably end up
being the wi winner just because of the
caveat of being able to to duplicate the
powers or the the fighting style of
anybody she sees ultimately though she's
going against neyar the Submariner and
Neymar the Submariner does not hold back
he looks amazing as the Phoenix but
neyar man here's the thing man people
sleep on Neymar sometimes that's the
thing like people people have this
tendency to underestimate neyar like
right like he's got Wings on his feet
and like he was the first mutant in the
in like Marvel comic you know the first
person to ever be publishes a mutant
Marvel Comics rahu right he's just he he
lives in the water and then who lives in
a pineapple under the sea Ney more the
Submariner like that's that's people
just kind of sleep on him and that's
basically it but Neymar Neymar is pretty
legit right he's he's pretty awesome but
the whole idea behind this is we get
this this interesting little bit of a
discussion with Neymar the Submariner
where he kind of talks about when he was
a little kid and a bull shark that was a
lot bigger than him had basically gone
to bite him and he drug it to the
surface and then he threw it on the
surface and then his mom chastised him
right she yelled at him at the idea that
he was acting very much like a surface
dweller right that just you know that we
on the surface just more or less kill
indiscriminately and there's no real
reason why I mean you know we do it to
like you know to to feed ourselves but
we also do it for you know Petty
vendettas and things like that and so
the idea was that she kind of pose a
question to him like are you going to be
the kind of person who kills
indiscriminately like people on the
surface or are you going to be like a
king down in Atlantis and the response
of neyar was pretty interesting there
where he basically said that the the
philosophy he held is that he would kill
anything that tried to attack him so
that everything in the ocean would learn
not to attack him and his mother found
happiness in that right she was
satisfied with that answer and he
basically carries this over right in the
sense that with Ney the Submariner it's
not enough to be a king of Atlantis
right that's one of the things to
understand it's not enough that he's a
king of Atlantis he wants the surface
world to know not to mess with him
either but Neymar is one of these guys
where he always kind of has a chip on
his shoulder if I'm being honest right
like the world's got it out for him he's
always got to prove to the world that
he's a top dog right just kind of walk
around with a chip you know like that
kind of a thing like he's always got
something to prove but the important
thing here is even with the abilities
that Ekko has the reality is her
weakness comes in the fact that she's
never faced someone like neore the a
mariner underwater right it's just a
situation she's never been exposed to
before now having said that following
this fight she would become capable in
doing the problem is that Neymar send
you know basically you know sends a
bunch of sharks on her and then attacks
her sends her down below into the Marana
trench and then more or less leaves her
for dead right and that's just kind of
it so he ultimately ends up becoming
quote unquote the winner of this fight
and so from there you switch over to
what's probably one of the more
interesting fights here which is Shen
Chi and Captain America now here's the
thing to understand about this right
when it comes to shangi he's a Master of
Kung Fu right he's a master of of really
Kung Fu and woou if we're being honest
with ourselves but the thing about
Captain America is he is versatile in a
multitude of different fighting styles
and is a master in some of them right so
it's one of these things right who wins
this fight a jack of all trades or a
master of one thing and so it's it's
it's kind of cool there because one of
the things that's kind of hit at here by
Jason Aaron is that changqi is in some
ways not as prodigious of a fighter as
Captain America is and I would kind of
argue that point right I would argue
that Shen Chi is a much better fighter
than captain America but Captain America
also knows multiple fighting styles and
that's one of the interesting things
there because when you look at shangqi
and the idea that he taught Peter Parker
the way of the spider and taught him his
own fighting style that it wasn't rooted
in like taekwondo or Judo or Brazilian
jiu-jitsu right or kimpo or anything
like that it was just rooted in in what
is effectively Kung Fu and Wu and so
it's interesting to see this because
ultimately you have this kind of a a
little smidge of a discussion here where
Captain America kind of talks about the
idea that all of them has spent so long
fighting over who it is is that should
not be the the host of The Phoenix force
that none of them have asked the
question who should it be and in Captain
America's eyes it should be Shang Chi
and the reason for this is because
shangi is is probably one of the most
gifted fighters on the face of the
planet but what makes him so capable and
what makes shangi such a great person to
have on your team despite the fact that
all he can really do is hand toand
fighting is he's so good at centering
himself he's so good at putting emotion
at Bay and fighting like just cleanly
and logically right just focusing on the
situation at hand and moving forward
forward in that capacity and that's why
Captain America says like I want to
train you right I want to help you hone
your fighting style and your skills I
want you to become the best host for the
Phoenix now it's not as though Captain
America is like you know come hang out
with me and I'll teach you like the
wakandan fighting style and that kind of
stuff it's more or less kind of helping
shangi but again I would argue that like
there really isn't much for Captain
America to offer here when it comes to
Shang Chek right he's just he's not like
he's this rash and Reckless kid who's
just fighting more with heart than mind
he's he's clear-headed right he's
probably the best fighter on the face of
the planet I would say he is I think he
really is the best fighter on on the
face of the Earth maybe outside of
Taskmaster right Taskmaster could
probably get the upper hand on shangi
outside of Taskmaster I think that like
he's the best fighter on Earth but again
it's one of these these interesting
things where ultimately Shane chees just
like and really even Captain America
kind of agrees one of us has to win and
so ultimately shangi has like this
amazing moment right where he breaks out
his weapon and then you get just this
thing where he comes lunging at Captain
America and it's like this typhoon of
fire just following behind him and then
Captain America's whisked away right and
that's basically it and the whole reason
behind that is because Captain America's
stance was to kind of position Shang Chi
to make him the best host for the
Phoenix but that's not the way it's
supposed to be right it's just supposed
to be a knockdown drag out fight between
these various Heroes to determine which
one of them should be the should be the
next host right so you can't have people
working together you can't have them
like conspiring and looking to
essentially cook the books and stack the
deck in favor of one particular person
like you can't do that right instead
it's just got to be them just knock down
drag out bare Knuckles fighting and
whoever wins wins and that's why I say
like Captain America is a great fighter
don't get me wrong I'm not like knocking
Captain America he's a great Fighter the
guy overpowered Spider-Man even though
Spider-Man was really didn't have an
actual fighting style but but at the end
of the day like I would give it to Shang
Chi man let me know what you guys think
I'm curious what do you guys who do you
guys think is a better fighter in Marvel
Comics do you think it's Captain America
or do you think it's Shang Chi cuz I
really feel like it's Shang Chi here but
at the end of the day the Avengers are
kind of forming their own plan their own
sort of backup plan in the sense that as
far as they're concerned the Phoenix
Force can't really be trusted and this
is one of the things that I'm not a big
fan of in terms of how Marvel's handled
the Phoenix Force recently right the
Phoenix Force when it was introduced by
Chris Claremont Marvel Comics was more
of a philosophical concept than it was
just like a a thing that existed out
there and did some stuff right that the
Phoenix force was designed to kind of
represent like this primordial
life-giving Force but sort of represent
this idea that even the most pure of
people can become twisted and evil and
become bad guys right genan gray was by
all Sanders of measurement pure of heart
and the Phoenix force was this concept
that didn't really understand or want to
know good and evil right it was just
this primordial Force but when you look
at Chris claremont's X-Men run it's kind
of kind of this idea that like the human
race is an infection right it's almost
kind of like a disease or an illness and
everything we touch we screw up and so
when you look at the Phoenix for example
when it took control of Jean Gray that
all the the emotions that Jean you know
more or less experienced at least at the
time the story was written uh corrupted
the Phoenix Force now later on Marvel
changed it and basically had it reveal
the fact that the Phoenix just
impersonated Jean Gray and was not
actually genan gray but the way that
Chris Claremont originally wrote The
Phoenix and dark Phoenix stories it was
Jean Gray right it was literally Jean
Gray herself so again it's one of those
those interesting things that in a lot
of ways if you look at the Phoenix and
the dark Phoenix Saga it's a cynical
critique on Humanity right that we are
really just more of a problem than
anything else and so one of the things
that you get here this is kind of an
interesting situation is you you have a
couple fights to take place and none of
them are of any major significance you
do get to see She-Hulk as uh as as the
Phoenix which is okay I mean it's
interesting you know I mean you know
it's it's cool it's it's it's whatever
but then you end up transitioning to the
Ukraine right and you've got Chernobyl
the exclusion zone right which most of
you guys know from the Chernobyl
meltdown that the radiation there is
insane and unless you have some kind of
a protective suit you cannot go there
right or you'll grow like you know two
extra eyes and like 15 legs right it's
just it it'll kill you right the
radiation will kill you but that's where
the vampires largely dwell in the Marvel
Mythos and so when you have black
panther who's teleported there black
panther basically comes into contact
with wol rain right wol rain who's
imbued with the power of the Phoenix now
the other cool thing that happens here
is that Thor begins to kind of launch
this assault that's really designed to
distract the Phoenix alongside Carol
Danvers and Iron Man and and Ghost Rider
but the funny thing here is that the
Phoenix Persona basically manifests
itself to Thor and says no like stop
right like like I need to talk to you
Thor because there is a secret that your
father never revealed to you and so from
there what you get kind of focusing on
this Wolverine versus uh Black Panther
fight this is an amazing fight here and
the reason why is because it's kind of
this answer to the question like which
one's better vibranium or adamantium now
in real those of us who read Comics know
adamantium is better the only thing that
can really take out adamantium is anti
or not really anti vibranium uh anti-
metal from the Arctic right there's a
few different forms of vibranium that
exists in the Marvel Universe And
depending on where they landed it
changed the principles of that metal so
wakanda vibranium is the vibranium you
most commonly think of right the great
mound in wakanda by which the nation was
built and that's the metal that like
absorbs sound and all that kind of good
stuff but Arctic vibranium basically
cuts through metal like it's it's anti-
metal and so effectively it doesn't
really cut through it so much as break
it down on the molecular level as it
comes into contact with it now as far as
I'm aware we've never really seen an
instance where you had somebody
possessing like an anti- an Arctic
vibranium sword fighting wolverin and
and basically like cutting his claws off
I'm not aware that's ever actually
happened in Marvel Comics uh so I'd be
curious to see if it did right just to
see if that's actually the case by all
standards of measurement given the
principles of Arctic vibranium it should
right it should you know as an antim
metal it should be able to cut through
wol Reigns adamantium but it's one of
these weird things where M's kind of
like nothing can destroy adamantium
nothing can harm adamantium you know so
it Ma kind of goes back and forth right
but the long and short here is that
Wolverine effectively starts to get the
upper hand on black panther now one of
the things to get here and this is what
makes this fight so cool kind of like
you know Wolverine versus Black Panther
what makes this so cool is not just the
fighting styles that black panther is
trained in a Litany of fighting styles
and even really his core main uh style
of fighting is rooted in kind of a
combination of a bunch of different
styles that he's all kind of merged
together into an amalgamation which can
kind of be considered like a wakandan
martial art even though that is its own
style of martial art is what theor mhe
used but like black pther has his own
unique style but wolver rain has been
around for a few hundred years and he's
trained in pretty much every martial art
that exists right so wolver rain is a
prodigious fighter he is a highly
capable fighter he's not a master of all
of them but he's certainly more skilled
than Captain America is you combine that
with his Brute Force his tactics and the
fact that his body's laced with
adamantium Wolverine is a ridiculously
hard enemy to kill and that's why things
are so nuts is because between the
intelligence right the the mental
capacity of tchala combined with his
fighting style and his ability to think
In the Heat of battle along with
Wolverine and his his experiences in
combat the fight is wild and it's
amazing right it's just it's one of
these these super cool things now
ultimately Wolverine gets the upper hand
on to Chala right just by ferocity alone
he gets the upper hand on to Chala pops
two of his claws and then goes to pop
the third and the funny thing about that
is he kind of he he asked the Chara like
so how's you know so what's it going to
be right are you going to like take the
L are you going to submit are you going
to be willing to lose or am I going to
like pop this third claw and am I going
to kill you right and that's what tala
is like I would actually block it it's
like how in the world would you do that
only for only for us to find out tala
has adamantium teeth uh all right to
those you guys who are not new to Comics
this is what we call a plot device right
it's called doing it just for the sake
of the story this often times pisses off
comic book
fans it pisses comic book fans off in
the extreme other times we don't really
care I don't care I don't get mad about
that kind of stuff anymore right I've
been reading long enough I've seen that
a million times I've seen stories I've
seen comic book stories that happen just
for the sake of happening I think it's
super cool that like to chala's grills
or just like adamantium that's lit like
I mean I don't advise doing it right
like don't don't cover your teeth and
metal but the whole thing about this is
is ultimately like this allows black
panther to get this momentary upper hand
where he literally kicks wolver rain in
the balls and then basically gets the
upper hand on him right and like the
fight like like literally pummels him to
death like uses his claws and just tears
right through Wolverine right and that's
and that's the end of that now
ultimately Wolverine's healing Factor
would allow him to live and the way this
kind of seems to go as far as the
Phoenix is concerned is like if under
any other circumstance it'd be
considered a legitimate death then like
they become the winner and that's
basically it right so again you know the
fights kind of continue on and and
various people you know various various
folks facing off against each other but
jumping back to Thor Jason Aaron makes
an odd Choice here and the reality is
that anybody who's been reading his
Avengers run kind of knew it was coming
up to this point and honestly I'm not
necessarily against it essentially the
pH reveals that it's Thor's actual
biological mom Odin and the Phoenix
essentially touch naughty bits and that
it led to the birth of Thor now this is
kind of intriguing because for a long
time Thor's mom was Gia right the
sentience of of Mother Earth but the
truth about this is it never mattered
because Marvel never did anything with
it right it was just like it was it was
a thing that was there right and like
that was it right it was just a thing
you knew and so you just kind of knew
knew about Thor's mom so the reality of
this is you know anybody who kind of
gets pissed off about this I think it's
only really coming from one of two
directions one is because of how it was
done by Jason Aaron how it was revealed
or two because they just don't want
things to change because no one out
there right no one out there reading
comics like those of you guys who are
new to Comics understand this there's no
one sitting in a comic book store right
now who's just celebrating the fact and
has like all kinds of memorabilia that
that that represents the fact that guia
is the mother of Thor right like no
one's out there like that's one of the
greatest moments in comics right when we
learn Gaia was the mother of Thor and
it's a Hallmark of comic book Mythos
right like nobody out there in saying
that so in in reality I think it's kind
of cool that like Thor mom is the
Phoenix now the question to ask here is
what's Marvel going to do with it that's
the real question to ask but it does in
a lot of ways kind of answer the
question why it is a Thor so you know
literally far more capable than any of
the other asgardians you could kind of
chalk it up to the fact that he's the
son of Odin and just sort of leave it at
that and and it would make sense but the
idea of him being the son of the Phoenix
uh really kind of adds a lot of
explanation to why it is that he's so
powerful it certain does a better job of
explaining why he's more powerful than
being the son of like whoopy Goldberg
from Captain Planet right I mean that
certainly makes a lot more sense right
so again it's a cool concept here I like
it and I'm kind of digging it now of
course this sends Thor on a war path who
just kind of refuses to believe any of
what he's hearing and even Jason Aaron
kind of plays a little fast and loose
and says like I mean you know is the
Phoenix really telling the truth here I
mean Thor kind of accuses it and says
like I refuse to believe this and the
response to the Phoenix is well you know
whether or not you you refuse to believe
it doesn't matter right like it's still
true so a lot of it seems to be accurate
this is one of those moments in comics
where we're not actually going to know
it's true until Jason Aaron follows up
and confirms that it's true right like
Thor goes to Odin and Odin's like yeah I
basically bang the Phoenix at which
point when I was if I was Thor I'd be
like I mean damn all right cool man good
on you right I mean oh like the Phoenix
is hot like I didn't even mean to make
that pun I didn't even mean to make that
pun I didn't even mean to make that joke
but like it's it's it's it's a cool
thing right it's kind of an interesting
thing so ultimately the the the real
meat and potatoes of the various battles
that go on here all ultimately boil down
to really one of the final fights which
is between Black Panther and Captain
America and this is an awesome battle
that takes place here now so one of the
reasons why this is so cool is because
of the fact that when you look at the
comic book history of these two
characters there's a lot of respect that
black panther has for Captain America
and a lot of respect that Captain
America has for black panther Black
Panther's respect for Captain America is
not just because of his time on the
Avengers and Captain America's role as a
superhero and how he operates in the
community it goes all the way back to
the fact that Captain America helped
fight alongside the wak continence
against the German invasion during World
War II like literally against the
Germans that's where Captain America got
the idea of a circular shield and where
he got his piece of vibranium that led
to his shield becoming you know being
turned into its current form Captain
America has a pretty lengthy history in
terms of his involvement in wakanda and
fighting on behalf of those individuals
who simply can't stand up for themselves
or who just need help that combined with
his role as a superhero in the larger
superhero Community leaves a lot of
respect there for black panther while
Captain America doesn't always agree
with his motivations it doesn't always
agree with uh the things that he does he
understands why why he does what he does
right it's one of the things we've
talked about Black Panther would let the
world burn if it meant saving wakanda
like he would literally do that he would
sacrifice the world if it meant saving
wakanda the the fight between the two is
really more of a fight of necessity
because they're kind of being forced to
not necessarily because they want to but
they both have their own individual
goals here right tala in possession of
the Phoenix force would be able to
protect wakanda from any and all threats
that exist out there Captain America in
possession of the Phoenix Force while
it's not his first choice and he
wouldn't really want to be in possession
of the Phoenix because of all the power
that it represents he it could certainly
allow him to like protect the world from
seemingly any threat that was out there
again he wouldn't really use it for
nefarious purposes he wouldn't be a dick
about it but while all these different
fights are going on and and the fight
between Captain America and Black
Panther is seemingly dead even you do
get this amazing battle between uh
between Neymar the Submariner and
She-Hulk now one of the things about
shehulk is it's not as though she's lost
control that's one of the things that
she clarifies she hasn't lost control
she knows exactly what she's doing if
I'm going to be honest that's the one
thing that really differentiates
She-Hulk from like the Incredible Hulk
is the fact that like she doesn't lose
her mind she doesn't become like Savage
she has before but it takes a special
circumstance it's not her default stage
right the default stage at least it used
to be until Immortal Hulk the default
stage of the Incredible Hulk was like
Bruce Banner turns to the Hulk and the
Hulk just Rampages right and that's it
right just tears things up and that's
all there is to it with She-Hulk
Jennifer Walters could actually turn
into She-Hulk at will she could maintain
her own mind right so it was basically
you know a a good portion of the
Incredible Hulk strength not Limitless
like the Hulk but a good portion of the
Hulk's strength and then being able to
change back and forth it will right and
so the fight between her and Neymar it's
pretty intense and and She-Hulk really
starts to get the upper hand and then of
course it gets kind of nuts because she
literally rips the arms off of neyar the
Submariner which is kind of nuts like
she literally pins him to the ground and
then rips his arms off and then he was
just like he's like I'm possessed by the
Phoenix force and just like pops his
arms back right like regrows his arms
which is kind of nuts well it doesn't
really regrow him he just summons him
back and then like reattaches to his
body but in the midst of all that you
have Iron Man you've got Carol Danvers
you've got the rest of the Avengers who
really haven't been selected for this
battle uh basically the ones who were
left out so I guess they weren't cool
enough to be on the Kickball team but
these guys end up having their own plan
where they're effectively going to
charge up the The Avengers mountain
right like the celestial this Prime
Celestial they're charging this guy's
power up for the intention of firing it
off at the Phoenix and essentially
destroying the Phoenix or the very least
getting it to leave the Earth uh now the
reality and this is an important thing
to understand here the power of a
celestial is dwarfed by the power of the
Phoenix right the the the the Phoenix
Force's power is Way Beyond anything
that any Celestial would have right so
it's really more of just like a last
ditch effort and Iron Man even goes as
far as to say this is not a fight that
we can win right but like at the very
least we can just do something right we
can try a thing right and just hope the
thing works that like the Phoenix is
like okay you know what screw this and
then leaves but like if the Phoenix
decides to destroy this Celestial and
then destroy us and the world there's
nothing we can do to stop it and so in
the middle of one of these great big h
fight suddenly a hand emerges from the
ocean and then just absorbs the entirety
of the Phoenix force from those from
from like both combatants involved right
and then from there just starts
traveling around it takes the Phoenix
Force off of Jennifer Walters it takes
the Phoenix Force off of Neymar the
Submariner it snatches it away from like
Captain America and and black panther it
literally just Yanks it away from every
single person and the Phoenix Force
finally realizes it's chosen its host
right that now that it has its host the
the kind of Emissary or the the uh
manifestation of it as it was talking to
Thor leaves right and kind of leaves him
with a lot of unanswered questions right
which is how we know that Thor is going
to follow up with a lot of this stuff by
going and talking to Odin right and so
following that the Phoenix essentially
coalesces into its proper host
everything more or less stops they're
like okay like we like everybody stops
right and like they're just watching
this whole thing whole thing go down
only for us to find out the Phoenix has
effectively bonded itself to Ekko right
bonded itself to Maya Lopez why it is
that Jason Aaron has done this I have no
idea presumably because of the fact that
Maya is going to appear in the MCU and
the desire here is to raise the pro
profile of Maya Lopez and to get people
to notice her right and then get people
to be curious about her and in turn like
want to know more about her character
right so maybe it's worth us doing a
video on Maya Lopez explain honestly
we'll probably wait until like the the
the official launch of her character in
the MCU I might just make the video
ahead of time it's let it sit until then
I don't really know but regardless of
the situation Maya Lopez is now the new
host of The Phoenix what that means I
have no earthly clue right the Phoenix
usually bolsters the powers of the
people that it possesses but Maya
Lopez's power is to duplicate the the
the abilities and really just the
fighting style of anybody she sees you
know when you're when you're in
possession of the Phoenix Force you're
not really an Earthbound character
anymore you're not really going to see
somebody who's a host of The Phoenix
fighting Taskmaster that's not really
going to happen right you know oh man
I'm I'm the Phoenix Force Here Comes
Hydra well time to fight The Red Skull
you're never going to see that right
like that that's not going to happen
like Maya Lopez is effectively a
multiversal force of power now she has
the full totality of the Phoenix's power
so well at least assuming she can access
the white hot room she does but like
she's she's a a host of The Phoenix
she's a unversal and multiversal power
force galatis does not use Kung Fu as
awesome as it would be to see right it
would be amazing to see Galactus just
roundhouse kick somebody right like
roundhouse kick a Celestial that'd be
hilarious but like you know they don't
do that right It's Just Energy
manipulation that kind of a thing so it
may be one of these things where she
becomes something a can to Protege where
she can essentially duplicate the powers
of other people whenever she sees them
use them right there's no real
definitive answers here instead it's
just kind of like we don't really know
like exactly how this is going to unfold
but the important thing everything just
kind of goes back to rights and it all
just kind of settles back down and
that's it right like the the Victor has
been determined and that Victor is Echo
so with that being said guys we're going
to bring this video to an end if you are
new here to com explain make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace